What makes a person beautiful is their personality.
Everybody has a personality and everybody's beautiful,...
...but in a different way than other people.
Well, you kind of have to be confident in yourself...
...to feel like you're beautiful.
Otherwise, if you don't really have confidence,...
...the thought that you are beautiful kind of fades away,...
...so it's kind of your job to bring it back.
Well, my friend has freckles and she's like a ton of freckles...
...and they're super pretty on her.
And like I personally wish I had freckles...
...and she'll like cover them up...
...and that just shows that people have different ideas on certain things like...
...she doesn't like her freckles...
...when I think they look great on her...
...and they're pretty.
Being beautiful is learning all the lessons in life...
...and then you go from here to here and you start to blossom.